- After I've done my homework,
after I've learned all day,
the one thing I want to
do is just make music.
My car is the number one place
where I can just sit there
and make the music
right there in my hands.
At least until I run outta gas or battery.
The SAT is extremely
important when it comes
to getting into college.
You can never be too
prepared for something.
Like if you're trying to learn a song
and you wanna perform it to people,
ultimately you don't
want to go over it once
and be like alright, I'm ready.
You should always put time and practice
into anything you do.
Not only are you prepared,
you also feel confident
in what you're doing.
If you want to become anything
there's a correct step you need to take.
It's always baby steps and
it's always practicing.
I want to make something that
people can really connect with
and to be able to do that for a living.
I feel a lot more confident
doing things that I've practiced for.
You don't want to do something
that you haven't taken the
time to really get down.